bonjour patrice spinosi merci de
répondre à nos questions vous dit je
cite le besoin que les juges
garantissent les droits et libertés des
manifestants quand la loi n'encadre pas
suffisamment l'action des forces de
l'ordre n'en est que plus fort qu'est ce
que vous entendez par là que la loi fait
fi de la constitution dont j'entends par
là que aujourd'hui on voit bien qu'il y
à un certain malaise dans la population
du fait d'un certain nombre de violences
policières une inquiétude face aux
agissements des forces de l'ordre dans
les manifestations
et dans ces conditions il est nécessaire
que la loi garantisse et libertés
fondamentales de tous les citoyens
contre les risques de dérapage et c'est
exactement le sens de notre demande
puisque la question de
constitutionnalité que nous avons posée
qui a été transmise au conseil
constitutionnel
interroge sur la pratique du nas âge en
se demandant si celle ci ne devrait pas
être encadrée par la loi puisque pour le
moment elle ne s'appuie sur aucun texte
particulier et c'est tellement qu'est ce
que vous reprochez à cette technique
dite de la nasse ce que lui reproche
c'est d'être une mesure de contrainte
qui a abouti si ce n'est à une privation
à tout le moins une restriction de
liberté la technique de la nasse pour
comprendre ce que c'est c'est dans une
manifestation il ya une volonté des
forces de police et bien de limiter ou
de couper certains manifestants d'autres
et donc ils les encerclent c'est une
technique d'encerclement et une fois
qu'ils ont été entièrement encerclée il
y à une sortie qui est proposée à
l'ensemble des manifestants et c'est à
cette sortie il va y avoir des contrôles
qui vont pouvoir être opéré et on voit
bien le problème c'est que peut-être que
la technique de la nacelle est utilisée
lorsqu'il ya des casseurs à certains
endroits voir une médiatisation mais est
aussi un très grand nombre de
manifestants qui sont ici en toute bonne
foi qui vont se retrouver bloqué pendant
une heure voire deux heures comme ça a
été le cas à lyon dans la sphère où je
représente les requérants et à partir de
ce moment là on peut
demander si cette technique elle est
peut-être elle est peut-être légitime
mais quels sont les critères qui
permettent aux forces de police de
décidé de l'utiliser aujourd'hui c'est
laissé à la libre appréciation des
forces de police et nous demandons qu'il
y ait un texte légal qu'il organise
alors le conseil constitutionnel à trois
mois devant lui
qu'est ce qui peut se passer en 90 jours
il va encore y avoir des manifestations
dans trois mois oui bien sûr mais pour
le moment rien ne change
en réalité le conseil constitutionnel a
effectivement trois mois pour statuer
pendant ce temps là nous allons échanger
les mémoires devant le conseil
constitutionnel
elle conseille consulaires il va dire
est ce qu'ils feront cette technique est
véritablement attentatoires aux libertés
individuelles au point qu' il ya une
nécessité que un texte soit prix et si
c'est le cas comme soutenons et comme
nous l'espérons bien nécessairement il
renverra législateur le soin de prendre
un texte particulier pour poser des
critères à l'utilisation de cette
technique du nas âge il le fera très
certainement en reportant des effets de
sa décision dans le temps pour ne pas
laisser un vide législatif pour ne pas
désarmer les forces de l'ordre mais cela
aboutira ce que par le futur
et bien il y est désormais les garanties
que la technique de la sage ne soient
pas utilisés à mauvais escient
demain gérald darmanin reçoit les
représentants de policiers et de
gendarmes
qu'est-ce qu'il faut attendre de ce
rendez vous selon vous j'aurais bien du
mal à vous en parler je n'aurais pas
dans le palais fleur de peau lisse et je
ne sais pas très bien ce qu'elles sont
leurs attentes à l'égard de leurs
ministres qui est certain c'est que on
voit qu'il ya aujourd'hui un certain
nombre de contestations à l'égard de
l'action des forces de l'ordre
ticulier sur certaines techniques qui
peuvent être utilisées en cas de
manifestations comme le massage ou
certaines techniques qui peuvent être
utilisés dans le cadre d' arrestations
on a déjà parlé avec le pacage centrale
je pense qu'il ya une inquiétude
aujourd'hui et il faudrait que eh bien
on puisse retrouver une confiance dans
les forces de l'ordre excès de confiance
doit passer par une plus grande
transparence donc je ne sais pas ce que
les syndicats de police eux attendre de
cet entretien mais parce que les
défenseurs des libertés attendre c'est
que soit posée en principe qu'il y ait
de plus en plus de transparence dans
l'action des forces de police pour
éviter les débordements comme ceux qu'on
a pu connaître dernièrement en
particulier avec l'agression du
producteur monsieur éclair dont on a vu
que il y avait quand même des
comportements inacceptables qui
pouvaient exister aujourd'hui dans le
cadre du maintien de l'ordre
merci à patrice spinosi d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes l'avocat du
concept du collectif qui a donc fait
cette demande et vous êtes avocat au
conseil d'état et à la cour de cassation